[Music]
welcome back so in the last video I told
you about the Gabor transform and how
you can use it to compute the
spectrogram which is essentially a time
frequency diagram that tells you not
just what is the frequency content of a
signal but at what points in time do
those frequencies turn on and turn off
okay so in some sense it can be a little
bit more useful than just doing a raw
Fourier transform because the Fourier
transform strips out information about
when those frequencies occurred if this
was a power spectral density for example
a PSD as a function of frequency but the
Gabor transform and con's in contrast by
computing a windowed Fourier transform
as that window shifts in time you can
see how the frequencies evolve in time
so here I'm going to code this up in
MATLAB for a couple of examples and just
show you how easy it is to play around
with the spectrogram okay so here I'm
creating a simple two-second audio clip
with a delta T of 0.001 so one kilohertz
sampling and in MATLAB there's this
built-in chirp command so in this trip
command I'm going to go from frequency F
0 at time 0 to F 1 a new frequency at
time 1 so low frequency to a high
frequency using a quadratic path so it's
gonna go like low frequency to high
frequency like that okay and here I've
actually created my own version this is
just to show you that you can create
your own chirp so you could use the
chirp command or you could just build it
yourself and what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to actually play the sound using
the sound command and I'm gonna plot the
signal just to show you what the trip
looks like then we're gonna plot the
spectrogram using the one-line
spectrogram command in MATLAB okay so
let's let's start this out ok good so
I'm going to run my
okay cool you can hear that I'll run it
again in a minute this just shows you
the signal in time it starts out
relatively low frequency and then the
frequency gets higher and higher and
higher I'm going to run this one more
time so you can hear it like that okay
and now it's really easy to work the
spectrogram in MATLAB and all of these
kind of different arguments of the
spectrogram you should look at the
documentation to figure out exactly what
they are so for example this is the the
sampling one over the sampling rate
there are like how much overlap to have
between the windows how wide should this
get bore transform be and how much
overlap should it use things like that
and so I'm going to plot this
spectrogram of this X signal so you can
see how cool it looks okay so this is
the spectrogram here kind of bright blue
means that there's more power so the
vertical axis here is basically the
power spectrum at an instant in time and
you can see this power spectrum evolving
in time as we go from low frequency to
high frequency as time evolves from zero
to two seconds okay so this goes from
low frequency up to high frequency
really really useful not it doesn't tell
you just what frequencies are there but
it tells you at what point in time those
frequencies are there you can see that
there's some kind of banded artifacts
here from the numerix of how the
spectrogram is computed you don't really
have to worry about that because they're
very very small they have a very low
magnitude this is an a decibel scale so
those kind of red and orange peaks are
really really small numerical artifacts
what you should be paying attention to
is this bright blue energetic peak in
the power spectrum as it evolves in time
okay now I thought this would be kind of
cool this is something we do in our book
data driven science and engineering
where this example comes from in Chapter
two is I thought it would be fun to also
plot what is the Fourier transform look
like what if I just did the naive for
you transform instead of this kind of
time frequency spectrogram so I'm going
to show you that plot here okay so you
could just do the normal thing where you
compute the the
t of the entire audio signal all at once
and then plot its power spectrum okay so
I'm gonna plot its power spectrum here
and you can see that what I get is not
necessarily that informative I do see
that there's a pretty big big peak at
low frequency here but there's all of
this frequency content between about you
know 50 and 200 Hertz okay and what's
really kind of cool is if you knock this
over on its side so if you transpose
this so instead of plotting frequency
and power if I plot it the other way
around so frequency and power and I'll
change my X label to a Y label now now
this is basically the power spectrum
knocked over on its side
and you're gonna see that essentially
the power spectrum is the cumulative
distribution of my spectrogram okay so
this is just the Fourier transform of
the whole audio signal and then here's
the spectrogram and you can kind of
convince yourself that if you averaged
over time what you would get is this
power spectrum plot over here so the
reason there's a big peak at around 50
Hertz is because this was a quadratic
chirp so it's spent the most time here
at about 50 Hertz so that's why you get
the biggest peak here at 50 Hertz and
then it tapers off and gives power at
all of these frequencies from 50 to 200
Hertz okay so the regular Fourier
transform does give you information it
essentially is a cumulative average over
time of the spectrogram the spectrogram
in some sense is taking this power
spectrum and expanding it out to tell
you when those frequencies turned on in
time I think that's really cool okay I'm
going to show you another example this
is going back to that Beethoven piece so
here I have a Beethoven the Beethoven
sonata that I pulled from an mp3 and
converted the first 40 seconds into this
matte file and I have a bunch of
commented out code here that you could
use to pull out the mp3 file using mp3
Reed and I also have all of this code
here that shows you how you could
actually compute the spectrogram
yourself using this s TFT this short
time Fourier transform so this is kind
of the guts of the spectrogram code that
you could work yourself but here I'm
just gonna show you kind of the one-line
spectrogram output for the first 40
seconds of this beethoven sonata and i
think i should probably try to play the
sound for you all I'll do my best
sometimes this doesn't work live so this
is the spectrogram of the first 40
seconds of that beethoven sonata so
again on the y-axis is essentially our
power spectrum as it evolves in time and
you can see these kind of orange Peaks
are where there's a lot of sound power
where there's a lot of high amplitude
noise and those correspond to like
chords and the piano and an individual
keys being played in a progression so
you can see you know kind of all of this
interesting structure here as the
frequency content evolves in time let's
see if I can actually make a sound here
so what does the sound command I need
it's sound of my signal comma the
sampling rate so I could probably just
do sound of Y comma 24 comma mmm FS I
think I already saved this in my file FS
as the sampling rate okay and it's gonna
play the first 40 seconds of that of
that Sonata and and so kind of each of
those chords progressions is happening
you know in time and you can actually
see see the frequency content as its
evolving so I think that's really really
neat this is also just a great a great
Sonata and now you can kind of decompose
it and start to see what it looks like
in the book this is one of my favorite
diagrams I made is essentially this is
the first two bars of this sonata and
what you can do is you can look at the
first 40 seconds of your spectrogram you
can kind of zoom in in these orange and
blue boxes to these particular
progressions right here you can actually
see the patterns both in the in the in
the in the bars and in the spectrogram
and then if you zoom in to this band
around one kilohertz here I have
color-coded each of these these lines by
different keys on the piano and so you
can actually see that first of all this
piano is in tune and also that you know
kind of which keys are being hit at
which points in time so I think that's
really neat again if you go to my code
all of that comment about stuff shows
you how to compute the frequencies
corresponding to these notes and make
diagrams kind of like this yourself okay
so the spectrogram is a really really
powerful tool that allows you to to take
audio signals or just data signals in
general and break them down into these
time frequency plots that can be very
very illuminating and very powerful okay
thank you